MINHAZ KAZI: Welcome
to DataVis DevTalk.
I'm your host, Minhaz
Kazi, developer advocate
for Data Studio.
In this episode for
DataVis DevTalk,
you'll learn how authentication
flow works for community
connectors and how you
can authorize your users
to use external services.
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When a user tries to use a
connector for the first time,
Data Studio triggers the
Connector Authorization flow.
Connector Authorization
is a 2-step process.
First, the Google
OAuth2 flow is triggered
to allow Data Studio to
execute the connector.
This flow includes all
the necessary scopes
required by the connector.
We talked about the OAuth scopes
in our episode about Manifest.
In the first step, the
user will review the scopes
and complete the
authorization process.
In the second step, Data Studio
triggers additional OAuth flow
if the connector needs to
reach any external service.
This second step is
initiated by Data Studio
by making the getAuthType
call to the connector.
At this point, there
are several use cases
when you will not need
any additional credentials
from the user.
The first use case is
if you're not connecting
to any external service.
For example, if you're
connecting to the Google Fit
API, the OAuth scope will be a
part of the Google OAuth2 flow
and no further
authorization is required.
The second use case is
if you're connecting
to an external service that
does not require the user
to authenticate.
For example, if you're fetching
data from the npm Download
Count public API,
it does not require
any kind of authentication.
And the last use
case is if you're
accessing external services
using a private secret,
like a service account
credential or a token.
For example, the Stack Overflow
API requires an API key.
You can generate
your own API key,
store it in your
Script Properties,
and use the stored API key
every API call you make.
In these use cases, you will
return the Auth type NONE
for the getAuthType response.
Data Studio will then
proceed with the connector
configuration.
However, if you require
a user's credentials
to authenticate to
external services,
you should return the
Auth type required
by your specific
external service.
Your options for
authentication include
API key, username and password,
username and token, and OAuth2.
For a complete list of
authentication types,
check out the reference
link for the getAuthType
in the description below.
If the service you connecting
to requires the user
to provide their credentials
via an OAuth2 process,
you should use the OAuth2
for Apps Script library.
This will make the
implementation a lot easier.
The library will also
be useful if you're
using service accounts with
an OAuth2-based service.
In this type of
authentication, Data Studio
will open a new window
and redirect the user
to the service
provider's login screen.
Once the user logs
in and provides
the necessary permissions
to the connector,
the user will be able to resume
the connector configuration
in Data Studio.
If you're using the OAuth2
for Apps Script library
in your connector
code, you'll be
able to access the user
token through the library.
An advanced tip.
If your connector is
connecting to your own service,
you have the
flexibility to set up
any kind of custom
authentication
and authorization flow at your
end using the OAuth2 method.
If your connector requires
a different authentication
than OAuth2, like API
key or username-password,
Data Studio will render
the required interface
so the user can provide the
credentials in Data Studio.
You should use the Apps
Script Property service
and store these credentials
in the User Property Store
and fetch them when required.
You'll need to write a
few additional functions
in your code if you're using
any Auth type other than NONE.
These functions will
allow Data Studio
to verify the credentials
and reset them when required.
Details about these functions,
how to implement them,
along with code examples are
available in the Authentication
Guide linked in the
description below.
To learn more, check out the
links in the description below,
and don't forget to
subscribe to the GCP channel
for more great content
on Data Studio.
Thanks for watching.
And until next time, keep
building awesome dashboards.
[MUSIC PLAYING]